- Okay, so we got together,
my producer and I,
and we though since you are a dancer,
we thought that if I gave you some names
you could create some new dance crazes.
- Oh, okay hey.
- Yeah, challenge accepted?
Are you in for it? Are you in for it?
- Okay, yeah.
- Okay, that's light,
you can push that out of the way.
- Oh, this?
- Yeah, just push it.
It looks heavy, it's not.
- I could be here.
- Okay, oh you don't need, okay cool.
He's like, "I don't need this
much space to be amazing."
- So you just give me random...
- I'm gonna call out random things
and you have to make up a dance.
- Okay.
- Yeah, no pressure,
don't suck, everyone's watching.
(audience laughing)
Okay, the plunger.
- Okay, do we get music or I just...
- Oh yeah, start some music, yes!
(upbeat dance music)
(audience cheering)
(laughing)
- The plunger?
- The plunger, the plunger!
- Okay.
(laughing)
Oh my God this was the best one.
- That's it, wait will you do it with me?
Okay don't worry about
it. Don't worry about it.
- She was like, "You had me at this one."
- Oh no we can just do it right here.
Every stand up, try
that one with me, fast.
- Everybody do the plunger.
- Its the way we have to make it, right?
- I'll do it.
- Got to hit the hip.
- Here we go. I got it. I got it.
Just getting in it.
- Oh it doesn't smell very good.
- Oh it's stinky.
- That's it. That's it.
- It's stinky.
- Yeah.
- Wipe the smell.
- That's it. Oh. Oh. Oh.
- Waft. Waft.
(Laughing)
- All right. Great.
- All right.
- Hey
- All right guys, you all keep that going
- By the way, its all about the
hips.Its all about the hips.
Free the hips. Free the hips.
- Okay, how about the Roomba?
- The Roomba?
- The Roomba.
- Like the vacuum?
- Like the vacuum.
- Okay. Ah.
(Audience cheering.)
(Laughing)
- You bad.
Oh my God. You are hysterical.
- Thats the Roomba
- Oh mu God, you're funny. Oh.
I love that you ran into a...
Okay, the Gryffindor.
(Audience cheering.)
(Audience laughing)
- That's the broom.That's the broom.
- That's the seeker.
(Audience cheering)
You were doing the broom and the seeker.
- That's the broom. The broom.
- You're hysterical.